bonjour et bienvenue en fit l'écho dans
ce nouveau numéro nous parlons du héléne
le laboratoire national de métrologie et
d'essai qui est basée à trappes et nous
parlerons justement démission du hellen
avec le directeur du développement
christian poulin vous découvrirez
également le travail des ingénieurs au
quotidien
et puis en cette période de préparation
de fait nous partirons à la découverte
d'une pelle décinois ski hors de
décorations de noël les plus grandes
villes de france
christian poulin bonjour vous êtes
directeur du développement ici où elle
est née alors les u9 c'est le
laboratoire national d'essai ça c'est ce
qu'on a tendance à dire facilement
donc j'ai envie de vous dire ici qu'est
ce qu'on essaie on ne fait pas que des
essais aux hellènes vous allez nous
expliquer ça tout à fait le lnd avant
tout une société internationale
implantée aux états unis et en chine
elle n y attrape est ici à trappes
elle a une mission de service public
principalement pour aider l'état sur des
enjeux sociétaux du style sécurité et
une mission marchand dont domaine
classique principalement en aide des
industriels sur des enjeux de
compétitivité
quand vous dites et des industriels
c'est à dire que on va leur apporter
notre cerveau quand c'est des conseils
pour les aider à avoir des produits
mettre sur le marché des produits qui
vont être plus compétitifs que ceux de
leurs concurrents par exemple une start
up qu'on est à mettre des terrains aussi
que leur de nouvelle génération pour
avoir des termes aussi clairs tout aussi
performant mais en étant moins cher là
on va les aider à concevoir ces produits
là les termes aussi clairs ça vous parle
peut-être pas mais qui permet de faire
de mesurer les adn quelles sont les
entreprises qui font appel à vous est ce
que ça peut être des grandes entreprises
est ce que c'est obligatoire de passer
par le n e avant une mise sur le marché
des programmes sous lui ment pas
concurrents qui sont là pour répondre à
cette attente simplement les yeux à
beaucoup de savoir-faire et entre autres
ce savoir faire peut profiter aux
industriels pour les aider pour être
plus performant dans le domaine de la
compétitivité
on peut les aider sur des enjeux par
exemple d'environnement de sécurité de
santé de fiabilité donc ça veut dire
qu'ici vous créez vous même les propres
outils
tout à fait d'accord vous créez les
propos étaient voulez vous tester aussi
je reviens toujours son histoire de
dresde basque segi nage quand même quand
on a des antennes alors quand on parle
de fiabilité on teste par exemple
principalement des acteurs importants
pour l'industrie aéronautique par
exemple on va tester à la fois le
vieillissement d'un certain nombre de
choses et la tenue dans un environnement
extrêmement perturbé par exemple
actuellement on est en train de mettre
au point un mannequin qui va s'approcher
de l'être humain pour aller mesuré dans
des environnements extrêmement agressif
d'ondés électromagnétiques
donc ça ça va nous permettre aux gens de
vérifier quel est l'impact sur l'être
humain de dons électromagnétiques
extrêmement agressif alors là on
s'approche des fêtes de noël donc
forcément ol n est ici on teste les
jouets par exemple où c'est une activité
de toute l'année c'est une activité de
toute l'année parce que vous savez que
les gens test les jouets bien avant de
les mettre sur le marché
donc c'est des choses qu'ils opèrent
depuis beaucoup de temps dans le domaine
de la sécurité aussi on est un acteur
important dans le domaine de la
certification par exemple si on prend le
domaine de la santé par exemple tous les
dispositifs médicaux vous n'avez pas le
droit de vous auto certifié vous devez
faire appel à un tiers
et là le héléne à travers sa marque
gmail est un des leaders est un des cinq
leaders européens qui certifie un
certain nombre de dispositifs médicaux
alors ça vous parle peut-être pas ce que
c'est qu'un dispositif médical mais
c'est par exemple un pacemaker une
prothèse de hanche
vous êtes un établissement public
industriel comment vous êtes et financer
ce que vous êtes financée par des fonds
publics
l'état est ce qu'il ya des fonds privés
alors autrement pour la mission de
l'état qui nous incombent l'état nous
mais recevant sion elle est relativement
peu importante
le gros de l'activité c'est nous qui
allons chercher notre empreinte pour le
financement puisque nous sommes un
acteur comme un industriel classique
on a des clients et on vend des choses
ça veut dire que vous dégager un chiffre
d'affaires tout à fait le che d'affaires
du lndd par exemple c'est cette année ça
va être le land de 75 millions d'euros
en augmentation en augmentation depuis
par exemple entre 2010 et 2012 par
exemple la croissance du héléne sur sa
partie marche en scène l'ordre de 20%
ici je les lis on est à trappes il ya
plusieurs sites et les noeuds en france
mais celui de trappes est le plus
important parce qu'un concours eco
évinois mais il faut le dire il ya ici
près de 500 salariés alors le site de
trappes
effectivement le site le plus important
dû aller ne ses sites historiques
d'ailleurs c'est le site historique on
s'est implanté en 83 est quelque chose
qui est nouveau et qui montrent un
véritablement notre stratégie continue à
s'implanter à trappes
on vient de passer récemment de 9
hectares d'implantation ici à 13
hectares et ceci avec un peu plus de 500
personnes de profil les salariés on
présume plutôt des ingénieurs
techniciens alors ici bain
on a beaucoup d'ingénieurs beaucoup de
docteurs beaucoup de cherche à sceller
trois quarts de son poids sur les 800
que compte l'uds héléne dont 500 sont à
trappes
c'est un emploi forte valeur ajoutée
donc c'est très bien c'est très
intéressant pour les pour les gens des
yvelines parce que on offre d'emploi à
forte valeur ajoutée
et là vous dites on va passer de 9 à 13
ha ça veut dire forcément des emplois
supplémentaires est tout à fait c'est à
dire pas forcément que des créations de
postes et si on s'implante c'est qu'on
passe des choses qu'on avait dans
d'autres endroits dans on les installe
sur trappe ça veut dire que il va y
avoir de plus en plus de gens sur trappe
ça vous arrivez à trouver du personnel
les recrutements se passe bien alors les
recrutements de haut niveau
contrairement à une idée reçue on a un
peu de mal quelquefois parce que on a
besoin de gens très spécifiques dans des
domaines par exemple de la santé on
parlait tout à l'heure de certification
de sécurité
bon c'est quelque chose qui compliquait
il faut des gens avec des profils très
spécifié et là c'est pas toujours
évident de recruter ces gens là merci un
festin pour vos explications autour
hélène maintenant je vous propose
d'aller à voisins-le-bretonneux à la
découverte d'une pme qui s'occupe des
décorations de noël et e l orne pardon
les plus grandes villes de france
les boules de noël ne les guirlandes qui
décorent les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines viennent en grande partie de
cette entreprise familiale installée à
voisins le bretonneux dans les années 60
le père de michel goulet créé moderne
des corps dans le nord de la france il
ne savait pas encore que sa fille en
ferait une activité florissante
la force de cette tpe faire du décor
événementiel pour des grands groupes
comme etam yves rocher ou natures et
découvertes mais aussi pour les
associations et mairies comme la ville
de paris l'entreprise familiale a
remporté l'appel d'offres de la capitale
pour trois ans un carnet de commandes
bien fourni qui impose un rythme de
travail soutenu tout au long de l'année
les premières demandes pour les vitrines
arrive au mois de janvier elle donc en
janvier
on commence à réfléchir en janvier
février ont fait des salons en france à
l'étranger pour aller voir un petit peu
quelles sont les tendances couleurs et
autres et en fait on travaille quand
même toute l'année une activité qui se
faisait avec cette employée il ya encore
un an les avec la réduction des budgets
communication de la plupart des
entreprises et mary cliente
michel goulet n'a pu garder que ses deux
filles et une troisième salarié son
chiffre d'affaires s'est écroulé on
était sur un million 8 1 millions 9 ya
deux ans et on est descendu à 1 million
l'année dernière donc mon idée c'est de
remonter tout doucement vers les 1
millions 5
je pense que après il faut pas non plus
aller ni trop vite ni vouloir trop il
faut savoir bien faire ce qu'on fait et
puis rester raisonnable comptant sur une
diversification de son activité hors
période de noël la chef d'entreprise
espère recruter au moins deux personnes
dans les années à venir et pouvoir
ensuite laissé les rênes de la société à
ses filles comme son père l'avait fait à
l'époque
en attendant le laboratoire jouait du
héléne évidemment c'est en période de
fêtes alors je suis venu apporter un peu
une petite peluche un chien un carlin
laurence mahec d'aline bonjour vous êtes
technicien dci et vous allez me tester
mon chien je vous laisse moi la paix
puis subir tout ce que vous voulez voilà
et ben je vais commencer par tirer sur
ses yeux en fait je veux faire un essai
de traction à 90 newton pour voir si les
yeux ne s'arrache pas et pour voir s'il
ne risquerait pas des trains gérés par
un enfant dans 90 newton pour moi ça ne
veut absolument rien dire sale calais le
pré 9 kg d'accord alain et quand vous
dites 9 kg c'est une norme parce que
c'est la force d'un enfant absolument
c'est une norme européenne qui définit
les les exigences à respecter
ici l'homme ne s'est pas décrocher c'est
bon signe donc c'est bon signe
qu'est-ce qu'on peut tester d'autres
une peluche on peut tester aussi la
résistance des coutures de manière à
voir si l'enfant n'aurait pas accès au
rembourrage risquerait de s'étouffer
avec pour cet essai on utilise ses
pinces
c'est pareil que vous allez lui apporter
une traque là je vais tirer à 7 kg 7 kg
un petit peu moins voilà un petit peu
moins de la même manière
voilà tout se passe bien pour ce petit
chien donc là il n'y a pas de risque
d'accès au rembourrage par l'enfant
alors qu'est ce qui se serait passé si
par exemple l'oeil s'étaient arrachées
alors s'il s'était arrachée on a ce
gabarit qui permet de vérifier ce
gabarit représente la gorge de l'enfant
en fait ça permet de vérifier si
l'enfant ne peut pas les ingérer risqué
de s'étouffer avec et dans l'hypothèse
où alors là c'est une hypothèse la plus
dramatique l'enfant peut il s'avère que
l'enfant peut ingérer l'oeil essai tout
fait ça veut dire que ce chien ne peut
pas être mis sur le marché des solutions
à seulement parce qu'ils présentent un
danger pour l'enfant
je présume qu avec les années avec les
évolutions notamment dans les jouets il
ya eu des demandes supplémentaires qui
sont arrivés notamment des au niveau des
produits toxiques et pas sûr parce qu'il
ya des petites peintures sur le sur
l'oeil tout à fait puis les colorants la
composition du jouet dans son ensemble
donc actuellement on recherche huit
substances dangereuses comme par exemple
le mercure l'arsenic le plomb et 11
juillet de l'année prochaine
la réglementation va se renforcer en
fait et on va rechercher 19 substances
dangereuses aussi des limites à ne pas
dépasser pour être abaissée de manière à
renforcer encore la sécurité des jouets
en tout cas lui il a passé le test
oui enfin les deux tests qu'on a fait là
oui tout va bien d'accord il ya d'autres
tests aussi qui peut être lui être
appliqué par exemple l'inflammabilité
absolument donc là dans ce cas là c'est
pareil le joueur ne doit pas brûler bien
sûr il peut brûler mais il ya une
vitesse de propagation des flammes
maximale à respecter le temps que
l'enfant puisse rejeter le jouer loin de
lui le marquage chez eux normalement est
obligatoire pour vendre les jouets après
baho revault pas rendre regarder aussi
la qualité du jouet en fait sur
l'étiquette alors il ya la classe d'âge
qui est très importante à regarder en
fait et puis il peut y avoir des
mentions qui précise si le jouet n'est
pas destiné aux enfants de moins de 3
ans par exemple ça c'est très important
qui pourrait présenter un risque pour
les enfants en bas âge
bon alors je récupère mon carlin moi
c'est bon il a passé ses deux tests avec
brio merci beaucoup pour vos bons
conseils
avant de se quitter quelques dates à
noter dans vos agendas la cité des
métiers installé à trappes robes roses
un atelier concernant les entretiens de
recrutement pour les 45 ans et plus
comment présenter ses compétences ses
talents lors des entretiens quels
avantages employés un senior réponse le
mercredi 12 décembre de 10 heures à 17
heures et puis toujours à la cité des
métiers le 13 un atelier intitulé faire
évoluer sa vie professionnelle
si vous voulez changer de métier ou
trouver des solutions pour évoluer
venez vous renseigner entre 14 heures et
16 heures à la chambre de commerce de
versailles toujours le 13 décembre un
atelier de quatre heures sur
l'auto-entreprise apprendre les règles
de base comprendre le fonctionnement de
l'auto entreprenariat et développer sa
propre auto entreprise et puis il faut
mieux en rire tellement cela nous
échappe d'un retournement à l'autre
c'est une comédie sur la crise
financière proposée par les universités
populaires des yvelines et cela se
déroule au prisme à elancourt voilà
c'est terminé pour ce fils échos
prochain rendez vous le 21 décembre
vous retrouverez alice gastines il sera
question d'aéronautique très bientôt